okay so we just saw ready player one a
little background I have never read the
book I know nothing about it he has you
have read the book was not a fan correct
no comment so yeah but go more into that
so basically he's read the book I have
not um and we went to this was not
impressed by the trailers it just looked
like the generic Spielberg future they
does now except with pop cultural
references kind of is yeah but we went
in and I thought was fun I thought was
fine I thought was a cute little
adventure that yeah it has some pop
cultural references but they weren't too
annoying like that they weren't like you
know shoved into your face or anything
they're kind of having fun with it but
it wasn't there are little wings but
they weren't huge wings do you know what
I mean you know man I can lower the
Rings whenever they are like The Hobbit
when they reference a character it's
like I want you to be someone called
Aragorn el récord huh like it it doesn't
do that yeah and I thought it's just a
fun cool world that they created and the
characters are just totally forgettable
with the exception of the guy who makes
the Oasis the the place where they go
into the virtual world and oh why me
we'll talk more but that's my essential
thoughts what's your take it exists
honestly pretty much probably that I did
I don't think we're gonna disagree with
much on this cuz I kind of just you
probably liked it maybe a little more
than me but I didn't hate it I was
impressed I came out of it going like
yeah I got wrapped up and do it a little
bit cuz i I didn't from the book so I I
guess it took a master like Steven
Spielberg to make this watchable kind of
have fun during a Spielberg film yeah ya
know there's like some standout moments
I think for me though is just there is
some standout moments and just a lot of
boredom getting
they're you know the only thing about
that is is that I was thinking to myself
every time they're gonna return to the
real world I'm gonna hate this movie but
they're kind of not honestly it kind of
improved Sonny knows that see I I still
thought it was kind of dull but it was
like it smartly doesn't stay in the real
world very long a key keeps coming back
to the Oasis so it's practically an
animated I have to see I needed to see
them in real life and like they were
likable in a way in real life that there
were moments where I'm just like I wish
they could ditch the avatar sometimes
like I don't know like when they're
hanging out in the van I'm just like
yeah I like these people here like like
no nobody quit there's no character in
this ie nobody grabs you like we're the
bar set low so there's no character so
it's like I'm the bar said being low I'm
just like yeah I kind of like watching
them like hang out like as their real
selves and you know it but I think a lot
of that is the main character even like
20 times in this movie he goes no no no
no any kind of looks like Shia LaBeouf
idea was obviously he was the original
idea when Spielberg was thinking this
would have been a way more interesting
film Shia LaBeouf like the full beard
and everything know that should have
been his avatar that would have been a
way more interesting avatar but that's
kind of my problem with the characters
is that I wish they were a little weird
or a little funny or a little kooky ER
and stuff and they were the the real
characters are in the book a little
weirder and a little um in this this one
I liked all the characters but but the
Lee it's the same problem with the book
which is everybody but the lead is more
interesting you can be like whoa none of
them grab to be fine but they're still
more interesting than the lead right
yeah no it's total Harry Potter's
syndrome like right there it's the same
problem this time
where I'm just like why is this movie
not about the girl like she's the one
who's more interesting is helping to
leave this revolution is like why isn't
this about her and I have the same issue
in the book I would like when I've got
like 2/3 of the way through it I'm just
like I really want to know more about
her I'm sick of listening to this kid
prattle on about 80 shit you know and
Barak you're gonna be disappointed
oh the way she looks you're gonna be so
disappointed
I'm waiting to see like what this is
cause like you know I know we read those
no no it is the exact okay I'm shitting
you're not it did they did the exact
same thing in the book where it's just
like no it's like she's got all these
self-esteem and she's like oh no oh no I
like you like you can't you can't see me
because reasons and this and that and I
was like well fret at first I thought
maybe she really is gonna be a 400-pound
yeah dad named Chuck from Detroit which
I thought would have been amazing and
there's a total tease because I was just
like that would have been awesome
and then you're just saying I reading
this like oh man that's like they never
have the balls to do that so it's just
like I'm like good so I was thinking I'm
like watch a thousand bucks she's gonna
be some hot chick
I remember reading the book thinking
she's gonna be some hot chick this is a
tease in real life she's gonna be a hot
chick and then this is like yeah big
surprise she's a hot chick away it's
just like and we're during the pull kids
the same thing it's just like and she
had like a red mark on her face I was
like a sunburn that's it
like the Phantom of the Opera like the
the freaking of Gerard Butler one like
it was the same it was the same thing
where it's just like eyes got this
little scar on my face I just remember
reading the book going that's it that's
the because they built it up even more
in the book I'm like that's your big
reveal and like Oh boohoo she's still
smoking hot it's like because god help
us if Hollywood like you know is just
like oh no encourage yeah no both of
them yeah both of them like God help us
if like she really was like you know a
400 in Detroit which would probably be
the reality well and what's interesting
is that you know I can see are having
self-esteem issues I mean
anybody yeah that's driving that my if
you're gonna build it all it was built
up to such a degree that I thought she's
a pair of collegiate cuz there's she's
like Stephen Hawking I guess that
wouldn't work if you have to walk around
but I was like I thought really I was
like you know is over my leg I know I
was just like yeah this is gonna be
something else ask if you're looking for
Jake in this movie there's a million
plot holes but it's again I don't think
it's that kind of movie I think it's one
of those really ok this is a kind of a
fantasy sci-fi advanced this I will say
this one much more than the book got the
idea that maybe we shouldn't take it too
seriously because like I it's got I
don't know what if you like to put cool
great I I'm not gonna tell you how to
live your life like that's awesome I
just but there's a lot of people talk
about it's like no it's it's like
life-changing it's this in the end just
like y'all don't watch anime cuz like
every year there's like one of these
stories out coming out of Japan and it's
like you could go through hack dot
whatever there's a sword art online or
log horizon there's like a million of
these so I'm like well it isn't really
new and then like reading the book I'm
like it it was like I don't know I never
figured out like I I can't thinking well
maybe this isn't meant to be taken
seriously but so many people take it
really serious like when I talk I'm like
you don't get it like I'm like what is
it again like but I so I don't know I
feel like the movie though definitely is
skewing more towards like no this is
just kind of know it just joke this is a
joke guys yeah it works best when it it
totally works best when it does yeah
well here's the thing I think with a
traditional Spielberg film even like you
know the good action films they're even
the bad actually feels whatever is that
they're I feel like kind of older
Spielberg would spend more time in the
real world to really get to know these
people and sort of build up going into
you know the virtual reality realm and
stuff like that but this one doesn't do
that and I think again kind of smartly
so because I feel like if Spielberg's
kind of felt a little behind in kind of
in filmmaking a little bit like
particularly like it just saw BFG and
I'm like dough feels a little behind
even in this though no no by me but but
you know
I'm saying we're saying a lot of these
specials I'm just like well this just
looks like anything on my ps4 yeah okay
but like what with the FG you're
supposed to totally buy that this human
kids with this cg giant with motion
capture and he's really there in these
RJ but it's it's an animated film that's
really all it is where with this there
is the real world but when they enter
the VR well it's supposed to look kind
of fake but even for kind of fake it
looks pretty good like it's actually in
the camera whooshing around and showing
these different worlds and you got
watching a million times and see what
all the references are I don't know it
just look kind of fishy to me
no no I'm like wait it looks fake but
look cool it look neat there are parts
of it they were cool I just it was very
I don't know reading the book I just
thought well if reality is such this
bland drab colorless world where should
it be more come nobody has but yeah I
just was just like this is a bland drab
kind of colorless world like everything
is like this weird washed out either
like grays purples magentas they're all
kind of ugly there's like a few really
pretty scenes in this movie but for the
most ones they're all kind of like ugly
colors and I'm like huh I would have
thought like they would have gone out of
their way to make this look last feel
Burke's thing now it's like everything
has to look hello oh my god and by the
way I never ever wanna fucking hear
about JJ Abrams as lens flares again oh
that's a head words been doing effort I
know he's just gotten worse like the
freaking car chase was just all lens
flares oh I'm not saying that the car
chase itself was bad but I'm just like
there were so many times there wasn't da
like cuz there would just be these
blends flares everywhere and I'm like
I'd like to see the car chase without
like these lens flares like you know it
was nothing so fast that didn't bother
me so no no I just have this lens where
after lens flare after and I'm just like
is this like a thing now where he's like
in a competition with Abrams is like oh
you think you can mimic me
yeah well top this shit you know what it
is it felt like instance people were
trying to say you know I'm gonna be the
filmmaker I'm gonna live up to my name
Spielberg him get show off this and show
off that there there is showing up it
seems a little bit more
I'm showing off for farm-like in that
car chase like I feel like you know SP
work maybe like five years ago or
something like like to do that all in
one shot or some sort of gimmick like
that in this but I felt like that this
kept the energy high was entertaining
and it like it did look super real but
it looked really cool somehow even
though the cameras spinning around
constantly I I could focus on everything
and stuff was coming up really well but
I can identify everything that was
coming up and I was really impressed by
that same thing with the end battle I
thought like dancing movie and it was
also the best damn thing in the book but
I know it's like I don't get that speed
was like I'm showing out to be the
greatest swimmer I just feel like I'm
just a filmmaker on this one like it
didn't I didn't get a ton of passion out
of it I just got him just like here's
some action scenes and they're they're
decently done like it wasn't until the
battle where I just really got all of a
sudden like woke up and it was the same
thing in the book like in the book I was
like did this guy like write the finale
first and then go backwards cuz it felt
like the finale was the most fleshed out
part and like reading the book I was
like okay I may need to see the movie
version cuz this is gonna be super super
cool and it's super super cool okay I
really found myself wrapped up in it I'm
gonna go iron giant Kelsey and I really
didn't expect that because I was like
you know I know it's coming but it yeah
it's he just like you know it's funny
there's actually three parts where I can
be like yeah like that was really fun
and really cool and I really enjoy that
and one is the ending it the other is
the opening with a race and then the
second is the the whole shining part
without shining was also sir not
appearing in the book because I don't
remember the movie and what I like they
did a fun - that's the thing it's like
you know much they're trying to recreate
it but then they're playing around
within their world and like doesn't do
what the book doesn't do is any of that
it doesn't like say like oh we're gonna
do a riff on something we're gonna have
like it's really just here's the
reference like there was one bit where
was just we were like and
to win you head to just basically quote
Monty Python and I literally just read
two pages of the Monty Python script and
I'm like like I feel like in a comedy
you can like get away with that like but
there's something about when we were
like no this like a thriller this is
trying to say something about like
corporators of it just okay I if you say
so but it it just yeah the whole shining
thing I felt was like an actual trade of
it and if the I know the author had a
role on the screenplay and the
screenplay does fix a few things and
that was definitely one of them are like
okay that was a lot of fun because you
like took the shining the idea and did
something with it you didn't just quote
it and it was really a blast too hot
yeah and yet you know and like I said
that there's a ton of plot holes in this
movie and the biggest one I mean just I
feel like everyone watching this is
gonna say wait a minute again without
giving it away there everyone's fun to
beat this race in the open Oh John I
figure out how and like maybe three that
came in my head I'm like oh they should
wear like this and they it's like I
think five years I've been trying to
figure this like my third thought I
think we can just say this cuz the
mysteries are garbage they have nothing
to like there is no mitt and there's no
mystery in the book either like it's not
like oh it the adventure mystery it's
the adventure one is the only one that I
think stuck out but the other ones I'm
just like it doesn't matter so it
spoiler alert I guess if you don't know
how they solve this but it's the first
race it's 15 minutes into the film
so here goes spoiler basically the clue
basically implies that you have to drive
backwards and everybody else is driving
forwards through the race five years and
literally companies are dedicated to
winning this race nobody figure nice
when you look and this is the world
we're in today where you've got people
who do these like speedruns and just
hardcore gamers but this is their thing
look for Easter eggs trying to beat you
know speed runs specific times and
literally just working day in and day
out to find every little cheat and way
to do this not a
single person thought go backwards yeah
or sit around and wait or drive into
certain parts of the wall like freakin
Mario Cart you look this is like the
fate of everything you know the world
and everything is based on this racing
could plays may tight you want don't you
think just like at some point like just
most of the drivers would just not even
try just get out like let's just look
around let's just yeah we're definitely
for something that's trying to be let go
this is the ode to gamers like did not
understand gamers their Matt all or how
they think are work cuz like you would
have figured this out in under a year
yeah you will figure this out like on
day ten I mean I see my people were fine
attractant oh I see them a game it's
that it took them that long to figure
that out and there's a time times to one
like they're trying to like this is
seeing they're at a dance club in like
in the Oasis and like all these people
come in they're starting to shoot at
them and stuff of them they're trying to
hide they try and shoot but we get out
here we got it's like just take the
goggles off you're going like why are
they just to know I have a Zemeckis cube
which is cool and everything but yeah we
can go by alan silvestri quoting zoom
back to the future so I think it's like
like a I think it's like anything else I
feel like it's decently I mean it it's
decently acted there's nobody who's no I
I just can't come out of it like I can't
come out of this thing it's this is a
bad movie it's not it's probably better
than half the stuff I'm gonna see this
year by far I think it's yeah I can't I
can't say it's great though either it's
just I don't know I just sat there for
large chunks of it just like it's just
like yeah this is here and then there
would be like threes like pretty much
the three scenes you mentioned but
honestly the first car chase only
thought was okay I actually thought it
was I thought it was way cooler him
watching everything above because we
knew now what was gonna happen and so he
could just sit down and like watch it
had like
I that just was super cool to me that's
like when you like cheat in the game and
turn the clipping off on the walls and
you can walk through and see events
triggered and I'll give this to like I
don't know if like we saw us on the big
screen so it's like that car chase was
super super cool I don't know if they'll
be good as good on the small screen I
might be like oh that's just I don't
know I know it's all CG but maybe I look
even more like CG on the small screen I
don't know but I feel like scenes like
The Shining scene and the big battle at
the end like even and the shining scene
was really fun and the big battle at the
end was fun the rest of it I'm just like
you know part of the thing is just kept
waiting to like I'm just like ants get
to the next scene what Spielberg used to
do really well which is missing here and
again I kinda get it I think they just
want to make a fast fun adventure film
and I think this is something like you
know over two hours or somesuch not even
that fast but serves a scene where it's
like the the main girl in the movie
she's like on top of this again will
give it away but you know it kind of
kind of this this the villains machine
and the villain looks and they hold on
for her for a bit just looking at it and
he's like oh shit it's her and she like
you know fights or whatever and you know
they're building up like yeah there's a
rivalry there they don't like each other
and I'm just thinking
no there isn't he captured her and she
got away the rivalry is oh he fought
Eames yeah there's no kinetic no it's
just she says oh my dad was caught and
put in the mail you said but but that's
it that's it's very much like tell like
and this is the same problem of the book
it's very tell down show like there's a
lot of plot dumps in this yeah with the
lead just monologuing just like in and
then I did this and I did this and but I
will say this it works better in the
film just because the book it's only
that well this actually can show it you
along with him saying I I didn't mind
that too and they did they did more like
the Artemis's character she comes out
actually I think better in this been in
the book cuz in the the book just pulls
like this like freaking tease like it
pulls the rug out for money because it
tells you how amazing she is
and as I'm father Korean how awesome she
is and then they
he just takes over and Gary stews his
way through the rest of the book like
literally that I remember there was one
scene where like he goes who's jealous
there was it was some arcade game come
to life to get one of the keys and like
literally the descriptions like a
paragraph it's just like I was in the
game this is cool
I made a jump I didn't make it so I
tried again it was difficult at first
and I got the key that was a bitch it
like it was just like then and it just
kind of played out like that and like I
was just like I I want to see like him
either struggle a little more or
something but for everybody claiming how
everybody else was so good and he'd been
following them he just pretty much
strolls his way through it the movie I
think I think the movie fixed a little
of it I'm not gonna lie I actually do
want to read the book simply because
people are like just so split on it like
you know I don't know anyone that like
you can really read but people either
like yeah that was really good or you
know like it you know it's like an IMDB
plot it reads like an IMDB plot summary
and it's super short so you could just
like breeze through it because this is
like hi I'm gonna tell you this story
and then this happened and this happened
and that happened in this Evan this em
in the end like it there's no that's
kind what the movie feels like a little
bit - yeah it's kind of stuff happening
there's nothing there's nothing not much
parent and there's not much character in
the book there's nothing immersive you
never feel like you're in that world
because it's just some guy just imagine
some guy telling you and then I played a
virtual reality game and I did these
things oh there's this cool bit where I
was in a DeLorean and like but if you're
hearing somebody tell a story of like
the grandest adventure ever about how
you save the world from his evil
corporation you better tell that like an
Irish story time really and there I was
it was me alone the sweat going down my
brow and there he stood 100 feet tall
and I sat there and I pointed my finger
at him and I was scared there were pits
in my stomach but I put that this just
none of that it just kind but even like
I'm thinking like you know service that
big battle at the end
it's like oh it looks so cool and so
awesome but at some point I actually
asked you know what what happens if they
lose I'm like alright so this kind of
Jackass company that granted killed some
people I mean fair enough you gotta stop
that but I mean like the gonna be the
most popular company in the world and
I'm like this see that's where a is the
film fixes some things the book at least
made it clear how douchey the company
was so I mean they did kill to quote you
got it wrong it would be bad like you
don't want them to get it so then that's
something the book I think I didn't I
didn't quite see the consequences of if
they don't make a like or at least I
didn't see this like sb2 warns that huge
a battle you know kind of thing but yeah
I still like that I I thought was fun I
I'm kind of glad that it was more quick
honestly I thought the big moments were
worth the price image it's got some
weird like if you're if you're in it for
those big moments that you remember from
the book or if you just saw the trailers
just like I was realizing Iron Giant
like kick some ass and I didn't I was
just like really were bringing the Iron
Giant and that's like I'm just gonna sit
there and just want to watch The Iron
Giant and said I I got sold I I know I
drank the kool-aid I got sold I like so
it it's worth it actually for that like
there were moments that I had a blast I
actually could have used a few more kind
of Spielberg moments the more than
thinking about because like okay at the
end again I'm not giving anything away
but the there's a scene where you know
that there's the egg and stuff like that
and the kid is kind of finding out about
the egg and discovering a few things and
it's constantly cutting back to like
this other kind of fight going on the
real world and stuff and I'm thinking to
myself you know like old Spielberg won't
let this just play out and let the
enchantment of it kind of happen and I'm
I'm kind of missing that a little bit I
see this in IV only one who really
wanted Austin Pendleton in that role as
Halliday the guy who played I'm trynna
guy he was in short circuit max from the
Muppet movie like oh you like that role
it was maybe yeah I feel like my life is
like this actor was pretty good but I
feel like this role was like made like
the way they made him look I'm like is
this supposed to be kind of a reference
soon
maybe you're right because it is very
similar but I kind of do what just got
him that I think yeah he's still alive I
don't know I haven't I know if I've seen
the waving of it wasn't even Christmas
with the Kranks yeah but he's an amazing
character yeah I was kinda like I was
like yeah I kind of really wanted that
the guy that got though was really good
I liked the best addition is that IROC
guy the the one in the giant skull in
the purple cloak
oh the TJ Miller TJ B has character that
is the movie I kind of wanted it's also
the back it's also the book I wanted
because it's just like no were a comedy
with thriller elements and like those
parts with him in it were amazed yeah I
was laughing yeah and I'm just like I
wish the whole movie was like this where
it's just like don't take yourself so
seriously like you can still have
explosions and and you know people
getting blown up and stuff but like
leave the comedy in because like when
they went for that comedy and whoever's
idea whether reservists kleiner or the
other co-writer for the screenplay who
was ever idea was I salute you that guy
was amazing you know and here's the
funny thing about it the last thing I'll
say about kind of old Spielberg here is
you know a lot of people nervous people
work for the big action sequences you
know and Indiana Jones was in Jurassic
Park and stuff like that and the fight
thing is the stuff we probably quote
them those from Spielberg movies are the
scenes where they're just talking like
Harrison Ford why the father or Sam
Neill with Jeff Goldblum and stuff like
that or even Raiders had a lot of great
lines please ya know and that's
something I kind of realized that it's
like yeah like he did do those very well
and I don't know if he just got really
good at Heather said there was no yeah
yeah and that that Raiders is a lot of
setup if that was here I would love this
movie I would absolutely love it but
because they're kind of they're not
awful there wasn't and this is where
like there was none in the but there was
no setup in the book it's literally just
I'm gonna tell you how this unfolded
minute the
I don't know how like they would have I
don't know I feel like it's it's better
than I thought it was gonna be I feel
like maybe the source materials dragging
it down or maybe they just didn't know
what that I don't know I liked it better
than I thought I just but I still wasn't
coming out of it like well that was
awesome I was like well that had awesome
moments yeah I actually with the
exception of a little bit in the climax
I can't come around the Easter Egg thing
I surprisingly didn't think it'd drag
that much I think outside those three
big scenes there were parts that got
draggy for Mavis um but it seemed like
we weren't there law kind of cut away
pretty quick so it didn't and everything
was back to just the journey maybe
that's it it's still a journey and
you're with them on the journey even
though the characters as well and they
added a momager he headed the IROC
character which it probably didn't drag
as much because they added that
character in mm-hmm and like I kept like
like perking up whenever he would show
up I'm like ooh this guy again okay and
like I was kind of just invested in that
and he wasn't there and the other one
it's just I think that that whole giant
shield was just something referenced and
they but they cut like they switched a
lot of things up it helped Artemis's
character her character came out better
in the original like he goes into aiyyo
aiyyo I and like the only thing that was
weird is um Simon Pegg is in this and he
played was it I forget his name but he
was a holidays partner he's got a huge
role in the book and he got screwed in
this Wow like he's just like where he
just shows up just for like a very short
amount of time and I kind of miss it cuz
I like Simon Pegg it was like I would
have liked to have seen how we've done
these scenes because the scenes with
that character in the book were one of
the few that had actual character
development where I felt like I was
getting maybe more of an insight into
him yeah well it would have and I will
say this the movie like switches on in
the last third and it goes at a pretty
good clip and I'm not
sure how you could have I mean maybe if
you put it before the last there but the
way they cut it in the last third just
felt like it really was flowing and
moving and building and and it's
probably why I like the movie more than
I did because I thought it ended on a
really like quick strong just fun note
it turns into almost a goofy comedy at
the end yeah like there's a lot of
laughs all of a sudden like okay I'll
take it like it's probably kind of what
I wanted anyway so yeah you know I think
everyone's gonna have like the one
reference we're just like oh dude that's
so cool they did that you know like even
though I think everyone's gonna have
something it's like it seems like
there's a good range of like video game
movies TV shows and I will make an
argument by the line they work everyone
and they work better in the movie than
they have in the book everyone was
saying there's a big problem with ready
player one the movie is that it's all
these pop-culture references but it
stops at whatever now it doesn't go into
the future 2045 or whatever it is where
are those and I argue there's a lot of
CG characters and things walking around
that maybe those are what's in the
future you know we as it's in the future
by the way did you feel that furries
were underrepresented oh yeah that one
furry shows up is like that brings up a
good point considering what I see on the
internet generally people's avatars
there is a lack of furries in this
universe Allah this whole movie is
pretty much just like VR chat the
adventure pretty um yeah they're all say
you know don't you know there appeal and
also the halo guys were fun but I would
have paid extra money if it was the Reds
in the blue also you know like okay so
it's like oh there's Chumley there's Ryu
there's you know character from halo
lands Mike bought it I thought it was
awesome no no but it's like you know
there'd be like five Chili's six oh yeah
they you know they've been oh there's
just one specific Chumley's like
Chumley's with just breasts that are
like the size of like like each other
and then a mini a chibi yellow to be
chun-li and then like a chun-li that's a
Jack like
if there's chunky and this therapy like
80 Chucky's yeah be like a million iron
job well I think that I think that was a
weapon though hmm
that was a weapon that was like well who
shoots in the game that was just
something I never it was like more like
all things considered but you know what
more vote yes for the pop culture thing
I I'm just more do it I guess they had
other pop culture like they change it
from that the book was just so skewed
eighties when this one there's a lot of
night like Goldeneye references I'm like
well that's 90s giant is nineties yeah
there was current stuff so good next
they went with a good mix it is
interesting though how it just seems to
start with Atari though I don't think I
saw much in the way of pop culture going
further back than that and I'm like is
that because Halliday designed the
system or just people can't think back
further than Atari cuz it's video games
well I think it probably makes it the to
like he grew up in that era he was
obsessed with that time so he made the
world kind of focused on Bandhan the
die-hard fans will probably really be
into this but again there's are things
we don't recognize so I just like more
current so the generation like a blur
this would they would go back proudly
would be the eighties that would be a
problem for the book I think where
there's an attempt at world building
through some world building here it's
just here's a bunch of stuff and it's
fine like I don't I don't know there's
journey bill tone of this film versus
the yeah maybe
I guess the tone of this film versus the
book is that the book people the tone of
the film just seems more like just
here's a bunch of stuff don't take it
seriously whereas the book I feel like
plays a little more to be over analysed
because there's all this attempted world
building and he the author gets into the
technicals of it which didn't interest
me much but you know there's a lot more
that in it in the movie I'm just like it
just seems like the tone of this is
pretty much just like don't take it
seriously we've got like the Iron Giant
like and a Gundam like
punching Mechagodzilla like just just
don't you're fine just just don't
question its its we end on a silly note
enjoy and I did yeah I thought was a
funny movie even though we talked about
the criticisms of it it's like I I
thought it was fun i I thought it was
just it was a good journey I thought it
was fun
enough I'd probably I don't think a
spectacular going be - yeah B - so yeah
there you go
um guys go check it out for yourself
even if we gave away spoilers I think
it's one of those movies where it's more
you kind of got us kind of gotta see it
I'll tell you what if you really can't
figure out where any of this is gonna go
in the first five okay if you're gonna
be like a really serene writing for
dummies this character fights this
character well Kate you can save that
but to see it is really cool that way
you know that's what you're going for
your going to see the trailer revealed
almost everything in that battle like
almost everything there's a couple
there's a I can't this her where who the
big characters were well oh my god I
won't ruin it just to be safe but again
like even if I was like I think you'd
still be like oh well I want to see that
is the one thing to say I think the
Internet's probably ruined most of it
frankly I read like you know the whole
descriptions of the battle like what was
gonna be in it you know or if you've
read the book you've already had it
spoiled yeah so there you go yeah I
think it's pretty much the same from
what I remember but yeah there you go
have a good time I I recommend it go see
it and I can see people really enjoying
this and going back using it again to
try to get all the other references and
stuff like that I was a good time they
could see people really enjoying it I
could see people really not enjoying it
I could see some people nugget I could
uh I don't think I could argue with any
of them I'm just gonna go right down the
middle
if you like it great if you don't it's a
very general audience please
like it comes in it does I'll say this
for something that people thought this
is the revolution and new storytelling
and and filmmaking or whatever I was
just like it's mostly harmless I think
it's a good time I think it's yeah so
cool that's about it we'll see you next
time
Dana game over
you